we've been talking about the increasing
role of foxnews in the immoral fiasco
that is the campaign and presidency of
Donald Trump and I've got to fox news
stories for you today shortly a second
story on today's show we've learned that
Fox News actually had the stormy Daniels
story which includes
multiple crimes for which people have
now been convicted before anybody else
had it before the election of President
Donald Trump and for political reasons
they killed the story they didn't run it
that's going to be the second story on
today's show but before we even get to
that there are now allegations that Fox
News actually gave Donald Trump debate
questions in advance of the debate that
they hosted back in 2015 and before I
give you the details it's really
important to understand the context here
okay remember that the right went crazy
when it was alleged that Democratic a
DNC staffer Donna Brazile passed a
potential town hall question to Hillary
Clinton and it's a question mark whether
it was really even a question or a topic
now either way it was wrong to do that
as a DNC staffer that supposedly is an
unbiased arbiter of the Democratic
primary what donna Brazile did is wrong
it shouldn't have happened but the right
went bonkers and it may have been
dealing just with a topic rather than a
question and in fact Trump specifically
raged against CNN when that news broke
you might remember that in the first
debate that Fox News did in 2015 however
there were so-called tough questions
from megyn kelly and there are now two
Fox News insiders plus jane mayer whose
investigative work on this has just been
absolutely touched top notch who say
that Roger Ailes who at the time was the
Fox News CEO told the Trump campaign
what the questions would be from megyn
kelly during that debate now I want to
be really clear here there's a lot of
informational spin happening around this
there are counterclaims saying that
actually
Donald Trump wasn't really given
anything he wasn't even getting along
with fox news channel at the time so why
would they want to help him there are
counterclaims that Donald Trump was
given questions in advance of the debate
but they ended up not being asked they
were either questions that were dropped
or they were bogus questions questions
that were never going to be included and
then there were also counter claimants
that yes someone fed Trump questions in
advance but they were asked by other
people than it wasn't the quote tough
megyn kelly questions that he was fed
that's not really the most important
thing here okay so let's go through this
in a kind of logical methodical
progression first of all is it possible
or even likely that Donald Trump was fed
questions in advance of the Fox News
debate of course right megyn kelly even
said so two years ago that that's not
actually the notable thing Trump still
performed like a [ __ ] but it was the
type of [ __ ] that some Republicans
loved enough to ultimately make him
President of the United States it wasn't
because he was fed questions from Fox
that he became president despite being
fed questions he still made a fool out
of himself and it didn't matter because
Republicans voted for him anyway so that
part is actually less interesting as far
as Fox News is concerned yeah Fox is the
propaganda arm of the Trump
administration today almost exclusively
yeah Shep Smith is an outlier Chris
Wallace is an outlier but feeding
questions to Trump would be both not
surprising and also not even necessary
for Fox to be what they are today which
is a de facto mouthpiece for the Trump
administration with Sean Hannity at the
top of that sort of hierarchy of
propaganda what's the real issue here
the real issue for me is that this is
another opportunity for me to mention
that the way these debates are set up
doesn't help us figure out who the best
candidate is that's what debates should
do and that's not really what the story
is about but in a way it is because
whether or not the questions were fed to
Trump candidates knowing the questions
ahead of time is of
very small piece of why these debates
are BS in total these debates are
structured in a way where the only
outcome is that you either do the Trump
thing which is insult people and say
things about Rosie O'Donnell and other
people little Marco and Rand Paul's
physical appearance and call people not
low-energy and try to score point that
way or you try to score points by just
listening talking points because
fundamentally the debates are structured
to have weak moderators in almost all
cases and in most ways they are way too
short in terms of how long each person
is allowed to speak to get into any
substance and that's maybe as a result
of the low attention span that many news
consumers have at this point and it's
just too easy - giggle up which means
just throw a whole bunch of stuff out
there at once
miss state the positions of your
opponents or was claimed that your
opponent is Miss stating your positions
and nothing substantive actually happens
here's one example not even from the
Trump era the first Mitt Romney Barack
Obama debate
Mitt Romney spent half the debate
claiming that Barack Obama was simply
mischaracterizing his points of view in
his positions even though Barack Obama
was accurately characterizing Mitt
Romney's points of view in positions and
it avoids any real and substantive
debate but it's not even fully exposed
because the format is too short to even
really let us hash that out here's an
example of a specific topic where we
often learn nothing taxes okay when
candidates debate taxation it's we
should cut taxes for the middle class or
we should raise taxes for the very rich
everybody needs to pay their fair share
we are overtaxed get into exactly what
your brackets would be what would the
percentage of marginal tax rates be and
debate why that's the plan that you want
because if you actually allow the time
for that to happen it will be very
obvious which candidates don't have the
slightest idea what's going on which is
a lot of them it would be surprising how
many of them that is
you need real-time fact-checking that
has to be something that is done it's
not partisan it's merely reality you
need to empower the moderators to be
stronger both parties often will
negotiate to weaken the role of the
moderator by limiting what the moderator
or moderators are allowed to do what we
have and I get it we started with Trump
got questions ahead of time okay what we
have are debates that if anything dis
inform people about actual issues and
they encourage a total lack of critical
thinking and this is just the first Fox
News related story for today let's now
go into the second one